there are new clues this morning about a
possible motive in the nashville bombing
federal authorities have identified the
bomber as 63-year-old anthony quinn
warner
dna evidence confirms warner's remains
were found at the scene of the rv blast
on christmas day
the vehicle exploded outside an a t a t
and t communications hub knocking out
cell and wi-fi service from tennessee to
alabama
authorities say there are no other
suspects in nashville
is considered safe molalangi is in
nashville with the very latest good
morning
good morning jerica sources tell cbs
news that investigators are looking into
whether anthony quinn warner
was targeting communications
infrastructure by blowing up that rv
outside that att transmission building
which is
right down the street there one source
tells cbs news that warner's late father
had actually once worked
at a t and investigators are also
looking into whether
he may have been influenced by online
conspiracy theories
into 5g technology
[Music]
surveillance video captured the sheer
power of the christmas morning blast
which brought downtown nashville to a
grinding halt
yesterday the fbi named 63 year old
tennessee resident anthony quinn
warner as the bomber according to a law
enforcement bulletin obtained by cbs
news agents found a note while searching
warner's house
that led them to a witness that witness
told the fbi they spoke to warner about
a week before the bombing
and that warner gave them his car saying
he had cancer
and didn't need it anymore gloves and a
beanie hat were found in
that car and dna from those items were
used to match the dna
gathered from the remains at the scene
we're still following leads
but right now there is no indication
that any other
persons were involved at least three
others were injured in the blast
these six brave officers rushed to the
scene that morning
saving lives probably about five minutes
after we're there
i'd say that the timer then started
counting down
officer tyler llewellyn was the first to
arrive charging into harm's way
as the rv eerily played the song
downtown by petula clark
over loudspeaker it played in between
minutes
counting down the bomb's imminent
explosion we
essentially made contact with i believe
six seven
apartments and asked them to evacuate
the explosion happened i saw this
huge fireball in the sky
at least twice as tall as our building
among those rescued were noelle and
jeffrey rasmussen
and their two children they ran out just
minutes before the rv
exploded outside their building just so
grateful they were so insistent
i mean if they'd kind of just you know
walked up and down the hall and said
everyone evacuate and left
i mean probably slept through this video
shows officer james wells
walking away from the rv just seconds
before the explosion
he said god told him to check on fellow
officer amanda topping
just down the street so i turn around
and start walking in the opposite
direction
and then three seconds later boom
so you know i'm not going to shy away
from that because that's what saved my
life
that's what got me to see my kids and my
wife on christmas
authorities have not yet settled on a
motive they are looking at all
possibilities including credit card
records which preliminarily show
the purchases of security alarms and
chemical precursors which are
you know perhaps the material that could
have been used to create
a homemade bomb they also have recovered
a hard drive that may have belonged to
warner
trying to access that but at this point
david they do believe
that he acted alone how are the three
people who were injured doing this
morning
well david those injuries are said to
have been non-life-threatening they are
expected to be okay we should note that
those were just civilians regular people
they were not authorities or first
responders
regular people who were injured in that
blast but they are expected to be okay
bombing on christmas morning well thank
you